[Music]
hello everybody my name is Nick Clinton
Earth engine developer relations and
we're gonna talk to you today about a
project to map global land cover at
higher resolution than ever before and
specifically what I mean by that is
mapping the land cover in each 30 meter
patch of the earth back to 2013 so this
is a very ambitious project and this
kind of global land cover time series
has never been done before so Earth
engine teamed up with cloud to make it
happen and we're going to tell you how
but first you might be wondering what is
land cover alright and the analogy that
I like to use is what's on the shelf and
so organizations all over the world
governments NGOs nonprofits researchers
businesses want to understand the
literal landscape in which they're doing
business so here's a more formal
definition of land cover it's the
observed physical cover of the earth's
surface which describes the distribution
of vegetation types water bodies and
human built environments and other land
cover types that distribution is a map
and so here's a map of the imagery that
I showed you a couple slides ago or
rather the pixels are turned into a map
and we'd like to do this at scale and do
it not only for the whole surface of the
world but for a time series and when you
have a time series of maps like that you
can start to understand processes like
the change in cropland urbanisation
deforestation the change in water
resources in your area of interest and
these are not just buzzwords land
in fact codified into the UN sustainable
development goals and so Google is
interested in helping to achieve these
goals and one of the key ingredients to
making that happen is just monitoring
and understanding where you are at a
given time
and so that's why we need maps like this
in order to get a lot of these at global
scale and a time series of them we need
to use a lot of imagery and and we need
to use a lot of imagery to turn all
those pixels into land cover labels like
you see in this map so fortunately we
have Earth engine to help you with that
kind of thing and what is Earth engine
Earth engine is Google's cloud platform
for geospatial processing and it's it's
got a whole bunch of good stuff
primarily raster data so lots of
satellite imagery but other geospatial
datasets as well and here's an example
this is the same image that you saw
before this is a Landsat 8 which is the
latest and greatest Landsat Landsat 9 is
coming but we want to turn all these
pixels and we are right up there
somewhere we want to turn all these
pixels into labels and so we have not
only images like this that Landsat image
but we've got lots of other raster and
other geospatial data sets that are
useful for making those kind of Maps so
we have all of Landsat all of centinall
from the European Space Agency
lots of modus Data land cover data
terrain data climate and weather data so
on and so forth 50 plus petabytes of
data in the Earth engine catalog and
growing daily as more scenes come in all
that data is not useful without a
computation platform so the data archive
is co-located with Google scale
resources to do computation and that's
what you need in order
to tackle big machine learning problems
like making time series of those Maps
all over the world and to tell you more
about the machine learning part of this
project is Chris take it away Chris
Thank You Nick
hi my name is Chris Brown and I'm a
engineer on earth engine so you're gonna
hear a lot about this today and I'm not
gonna be the first person to talk about
machine learning tools at Google but we
do need to talk about them here
specifically because to produce this map
it's a more complicated process than
just adding and subtracting some pixels
we actually have to have a little bit of
intelligence to do this so a brief word
on sort of some of the tools we have to
build up something like this we could
start with collab and tensorflow you all
know tensorflow
collab being an ipython notebook
environment that's free provided by
Google that has things like tensorflow
and GPU backends so we could train our
model this way we could build a model
this way we can then start to scale our
predictions using things like ml engine
kubernetes there's an extreme end we
won't talk about today but if you're an
app developer and you don't need to
create your own model like we did you do
have things like speech translate and
other API is built-in but we're going to
talk about is how we used things like
tensorflow collab and then AI platform
to make this land cover map happen so to
build a good model in our case we want a
model land cover we need a couple things
we need big data right and Nick was
talking about this 50 petabytes and
growing of data in Earth engine
we need good models this is something
that's brought to bear by tensorflow
and then we need a ton of computation
some of which is on earth engine but we
can't do it all in Earth engine and
we'll get to that in a little bit so all
right we understand this is a machine
learning problem we understand this is a
big data problem but we need to talk
about why so if we think for a second
about land cover we can also get a
little more specific and talk about land
use right so if we think about land
cover being what stuff is made of right
on the surface of the earth we could use
the example of a parking lot in a road
alright they're both made of asphalt
presumably and if all you knew was that
this is made of
faulted the way we do it is with
reflectance but bear with me here we
know material could you tell the
difference but you can't right it
doesn't just matter what something's
made of it's the arrangement of that
what it's made of in space and so this
transforms our problem of identifying
land cover from looking at a single
pixel looking at reflectance and saying
oh I know what this is to looking at
many many pixels and saying we know what
this is because we don't just need to
know the reflectance aka the material at
one point we need to know how that's
arranged in space
so this turns this machine learning
problem into a much heavier problem or
input stop being something like red
green blue or in our case because
there's satellites red green blue
ultraviolet infrared and a bunch of
other stuff too red green blue
ultraviolet infrared for 64 by 64 or
greater patches of pixels that's a ton
of input data and the question is do we
have the tools to work with this and the
answer is we do earth engine today if
you didn't already know does have
interoperability with tensorflow so you
can start to take these images that have
spatial context or temporal context and
make predictions about them or run
inference over these images and this
works great and why don't we stop here
right we're done that should be it the
problem is you can do this over a small
region right you can run tensorflow on
your machine over these images and make
predictions but things get tricky when
you want to scale it this is an image
where as Nick was describing 30 meters
per pixel this is of the United States
and is actually 500 mega pixels or so
something like that and yes sure these
aren't just 500 mega pixels these are
500 mega pixels over which a fully
convolutional neural net if you know
what that is was applied at scale and it
was done in about 2 hours which is
amazing too because what you know kind
of bringing this back to land cover maps
these are things that historically take
5 years to build for one year and once
we talk about scaling up our ability to
apply inference it's a big data problem
right this isn't just an Earth engine
large catalog problem this is an earth
engine with a big catalog with a big
computation problem and to actually
scale these types of predictions over
the world we have to get a little bit
small
and david is going to tell us how we got
smarter using cloud platform so now that
we had a train model we need to do
predictions at scale so the earth is big
it's really big and we have Landsat 8
satellite images for the entire world
for every 16 days since 2013 at that 30
meter resolution that's a lot of data so
how do we do this predictions at scale
with so much data first we have to sub
divide the world into smaller regions
now the cool thing is that every
individual region is independent from
each other so they can be run in
parallel so let's say we want to
classify this location the first step
would be identifying which region
contains this location and then we can
run the classification only on that
region so let's look into more detail at
how we do this first we have an app
engine server into which we submit that
location and then it computes the bounds
of the region that contains that
location which is then submitted in to
Earth engine Earth engine now extracts
this region and it gets stored into
cloud storage so this is how the Landsat
8 image
or at least that's what our eyes can see
this is the RGB representation of it and
it's kind of hard to tell what is what
everything looks kind of greenish so we
don't know if it's exactly like
grassland or forest or even water
fortunately Landsat 8 comes with very
sophisticated sensors that can see a
brother's range of the electromagnetic
spectrum that our eyes cannot see such
as infrared and even thermal information
and all of these gives a signature to
each of material that makes it easier
for our model to identify what kind of
material is within each pixel so as we
can see now in these other bands of the
of the
visible spectrum things like water and
concrete stand out a lot more than in
the previous image
so as these Landsat images are extracted
parts of them are written into cloud
storage as these piles are written they
trigger a cloud function that does our
request to a kubernetes cluster running
our tensor role model to do the
predictions and these predictions are at
a file level and once they are
classified they are now stored once
again into cloud storage this is what
the prediction for that area looks like
and as we can see every single pixel has
a value for one out of ten possible
classes as these land-cover files are
written into cloud storage those trigger
another cloud function that tells our
server to upload that image back into
Earth engine where it gets stored into
an image collection which contains the
land cover maps for the entire world for
all the years that we have extracted now
these land cover maps are very useful
for decision makers and other
organizations to make more informed
decisions about what what resources are
in the earth and every pixel tells a
story especially when we see the change
now one of the very cool things about
Earth engine is that once the data is in
Earth engine it's not only visible
within Earth engine but it's also
accessible to other external
applications which made it possible for
us to build a custom web application
using angularjs and Maps API to request
both the land cover images and the
Landsat images and then render them into
our application so let's take a look at
some locations here we are in Cambodia
what we can see here is the dark green
that's forest and all that amber
yellowish think that's farmland and if
you pay attention to the central region
of that forest we turn
the animation from 2013 to 2018 we can
see how that farmland is slowly eating
through this protected land land cover
makes it easier to quantify but if we
choose the Landsat images then we can
clearly see how this is affecting some
very important habitats in Cambodia now
we can also check this now we can go
into the amazons this is Peru and we see
this thing that looks kind of like bad
River that is going down and if we turn
the animation on then we'll see a very
interesting thing that this is growing
and kind of flowing as if a new river
was going was being created well this is
not actually a river this is toxic waste
and heavy metal residues coming from a
mine nearby fortunately some researchers
in Peru are looking at some trees and
plant species that can grow in these
hazardous environments to help clean up
the area and now if we go all the way to
Iran
this is Lake Urmia the largest lake in
Iran and we can see how the water level
is decreasing and this is due to the
construction of dams and the effects of
global warming in fact that little green
patch that we see in nearby the water
that used to be an island surrounded by
water so as we can see these land cover
maps tell us a story and have a lot of
very insightful information about the
regions that help us quantify what's
happening in there but they take a lot
of time and effort to create these in
fact to create a map of entire USA it
takes at least five years to create one
of these so we try generating the maps
for the entire United States and we
managed to get the maps
from 2013 to 2018 in under 24 hours so
let me show you a quote from Mahatma
Gandhi what we're doing to the forests
in the world is but a mirror reflection
of what we are doing to ourselves and to
one another but it's not all bad news
there's also a bunch of very cool
efforts that are happening around the
world something's not working there we
go
so for example this is the great green
wall project that is happening in Africa
this is in conjunction with a bunch of
different countries and communities
working together to plant a lot of trees
and edible plants to create a division
between the now growing Sahara Desert
and protect the forests in Africa and
there are also some reforestation
efforts going in amel in the Amazon
where people are gathering seeds from
the forests around them and then mixing
them with soil and planting in affected
areas here we can see how the these
plants look like after 3 to 6 months of
growing and then these trees after 5 to
7 years of growing we all share the same
planet and every little action like
using less plastic or growing your own
food will have an impact and you like
this project or see or would like to see
how it was created you can follow this
link and it will take you to our github
repo or you can share the story in
medium thank you
[Applause]
[Music]